you did the slap Me Out remix with uh my
boy Emily Chapa which uh that song just
went gold shout out to Anna Lee barrier
he type yeah super nice guy whose idea
was it to do the uh the leash thing me
that was your idea yes
because she got a little Flack for that
I know that's wrong y'all lame and wrong
for that he didn't do nothing wrong like
they saw like oh I understand but he
really didn't do nothing wrong he just
was doing what I told him
that was all the you were like look I
got this idea you're gonna walk me no it
wasn't even like that no it wasn't even
like that we just turned where I'm from
we turns up baby we getting on the
ground twerking we getting on our knees
we doing all that we doing splits flips
all day we going crazy so I was we was
already doing all that we was on our
knees it's working then I just said pull
my hair yeah see pull my hair we're
gonna twerk and walks I like it
um people get their hair pulled all the
time so I don't understand like what was
I don't that's why I didn't understand
there's an art to pull in here though
what you mean well also
listen as somebody who's been with black
women in my life you're not supposed to
pull the hair yeah we were saying that
too because at first Suki was like nah
[__] nah we just gotta hurt you can't
pull a black woman no you can't and we
just got our hair done and I'm like
don't pull it too hard that's why he
just had it all like just yeah left he
had it Loose because I'm like hold on
[__] man I just got all right don't
put my wig off you doing a little too
much doing a little too much yeah yeah
for people who don't know don't pull a
black woman's hair she has to give you
permission don't yes I have to tell him
yeah for sure he was like [__] we just
gotta hurt and I'm like [__] I'm like
been I don't rip this wig off
um tell me more because look when I was
growing up as a kid the only thing I
knew about St Louis was uh the Country
Grammar video with Nelly and they were
like that [__] look lit as [__] it was I
went to St Louis one time and it was it
was dope I had a fun time yeah it felt
kind of like like old yeah that's what
baby saying everybody say like it's like
oh like that's why I don't know they say
I dress old back in the day and stuff
yeah what's St Louis like because I
think right now obviously you're the
biggest representation of St Louis and
Hip-Hop yes it's like it is oh it's like
old-fashioned it's like we we back Daddy
like we not we see the new clothes but
we don't get to see that [__] like our
Mars went got all that kind of the Gucci
we haven't got [__] like that we got it
but it's gonna be a store that got like
the sale it's some little Gucci she
didn't hear something you know what I'm
saying we don't got to be there's not a
Gucci store in St Louis really hell no
it's not nothing like that like we don't
we it's like we get our [__] last we
really backed out of years like I got to
the new stores I see all the stuff I'm
like we don't got we don't dress like
this to her
but they'd be saying I just like that
with my little track suits and stuff you
know like I don't know you have to see
my little office everywhere and they'd
be saying I just like the little 2000s
but that's how that's how it is out
there and we watch old movies like old
movies oh Friday okay like [__] like
they're like uh Menace to Society boys
in the hood we watch oh [__] like
they're like that's that's what come on
our TVs that's what we we gonna say what
movie y'all want to watch and we gonna
name some [__] like that type [__] so
you guys aren't watching new movies am I
for real but if you do you gonna go to
the movies to see it or you know like
you just ain't gonna see it what about
TV shows what TV shows you watching they
be watching Power and stuff like they're
like
I don't really watch TV I'll be on
YouTube but if I do watch TV I watch
weird [__] like
um I like this show love at the Lock Up
um I like to watch Judge Mathis Judge
Mathis I like Judge Judy coach you like
all the [__] that you would watch when
you ditch school yeah just like like
that's the kind of [__] my aunties used
to watch when we was little and we had
to stay watch stay at their house while
we waiting on our peoples to come get us
so yeah yeah rest in peace to Jerry
Springer yes Jerry Springer Maury
Maurice a legend I like Steve Wilkos
I like all that kind of [__] tsuki
performed on Jerry Springer back in the
day yeah she did I saw that I said I had
no idea I didn't even know they were
having people perform on Jerry before he
passed away that [__] crazy you didn't
know that I did not know it's a whole
bunch of people that performed Jenny
Jones back in the day used to have
people perform you remember Jenny Jones
never heard of it Wiki Lake Ricky like I
heard of it but I never seen it yeah I
heard people say Ricky Lake but I don't
know what that is yeah Ricky lake is
like she was like I want to say she was
before Jerry Springer but that ain't for
real yeah